[Music]
there are two special cases we need to
look at while finding the HCF and LCM of
two numbers first case when one number
is a multiple of the other and second
when they have no common factors except
one which means they are co-prime let's
understand the cases in detail the first
case would have numbers like four and
eight eight is a multiple of four or
numbers like 21 and 7 21 is a multiple
of seven one number is a multiple of the
other why is it a special case it's
because in such cases the LCM is always
the greater number the LCM of four and
eight will be eight and the LCM of 21
and seven will be 21 and the HCF will
always be the smaller number the HCF of
these two numbers will be 4 and the HCF
of these two numbers will be 7 what
about the second case an example of two
co-prime numbers would be 4 and 7 or 3 &
5 both these pairs have no common
factors except one what is so special
about LCM and HCF of such numbers well
the LCM of such numbers will always
equal the product of the two numbers for
the first pair the LCM will be 4 times 7
which equals 28 and for the second pair
the LCM will equal 3 times 5 which
equals 15 and what will be the HCF of
such numbers it will always be 1 the 8
CF of 4 and 7 as well as the 8 CF of 3
and 5 equals 1 but
remember these techniques should be used
only to verify your answers
[Music]